boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are featuring Joe Hudson
today and we're gonna be talking about
conscious development we're gonna be
talking about his workshop
ty Turner's and what it means with the
future of self actualization thanks so
much for coming on the show a pleasure
this is awesome I'm really excited to
have you we have a lot to talk about
regarding conscious development there
seems to be a lot that is not really
talked about regarding how one grows and
evolves yeah and so you know how did you
get to this point of obsessing with like
human evolution to the to the degree of
hosting these workshops and helping
people get to their best yeah the it is
an obsession I think that's a great way
to put it it started just in my own
personal development so twenty-something
years ago I went to attend a meditation
retreat and some light years of
impossible it was it was it was it was
it was like they it was like getting a
drug and getting addicted and so on the
third day of the possum of meditation I
had an experience of I would say like
oneness with the universe and lasted
like eight seconds yeah and then I was
like hooked I was like how do I get more
of this and so which was an infinitely
horrible way to go about it trying to
get more of it or trying to get
somewhere but I didn't know that at the
time and I was like ambitious and young
and like just motivated so I just went
around and looked for every tool that I
could find to to develop myself and to
get back to this state that I had found
and and to the point where there was
like seven years where I just sat in a
room and looked at a tree worried about
money from time to time but like that's
what I was doing trying to get this
state back and and eventually that
started to wear down and I and I was
like oh it's time to like
have kids and and so I needed to make
money but what I realized was that
there's no way I was gonna make money
and provide for my family and be happy
and be the father that I wanted to be
unless I figured out how to make
business itself a spiritual practice
unless development of myself was part of
business and then what I found through
that and I found that I ended up being a
venture capitalist and all this stuff
happened and but one of the things that
I found was that my perspective and the
perspective of the CEO was the most
important thing to the investment more
than anything else right because there's
a golden rule of venture capital there's
no idea so good bad management can't
screw it up that's not how we say it but
yeah you know yeah and so so so I
realized that the perspective of
management and my perspective being on
the board and part of management was the
most critical aspect of the business and
so I started to coach people both in
philanthropy that I was doing and in the
venture capital work and then just more
and more people wanted it and so that's
how the whole thing turned out yeah and
it's and it's my passionate it's what I
invest in I invest in conscious
development yes my philanthropies and
conscious development and then what I do
on the side is in conscious development
yeah so this sort of the integration of
spirituality or the sort of meditative
practice or this one this is the
universe this sort of collectiveness
that that we maybe whatever you want to
call that source or God or yeah over
that that feeling is integrating that
into business yeah it's something both
huge for you as well as huge for you
teaching other people yeah and how do we
how do we do that
yeah I look at it I look at a little
differently now now the way I look at it
is just as justice there's just humans
develop in a certain way right like
little kids as a for instance like you
say to them hey what do you want for
christmas I want a GI Joe with the kung
fu grip what does mom want for Christmas
GI Joe with a kung fu grip what does dad
want for Christmas GI Joe with the kung
fu grip and as they get a little bit
older that sense of self changes and
they can identify I want a GI
but mom wants a Tesla right they can
start to identify that difference that's
just natural human development if we
don't get traumatized the natural human
development is unity consciousness right
so the sense of self moves from me to
family to tribe to country to people to
environment to to oneness it's just a
natural progression that happens as long
as it's not mess up so I don't see it as
a spiritual thing anymore and what's
really cool is that as humanity is
evolving in this way the economy evolves
in this way just naturally right so one
way to look at it is as the
consciousness develops our context also
develops so we go from this or this to
this and or this to if then then this to
truth is contextual to I can change the
context to oh wow it's all one right
that's the the same thing and if you
look at the economy the agrarian economy
was if this then that I mean sorry was
this or this the industrial economy is
if then than this where they're
optimizing every little bit right and
then we get into a contextual economy of
the Internet so every time that the
development of humanity kind of crosses
a threshold a whole new a whole new way
of doing business shows up and it's the
same in management there's different
different consciousness is consciousness
increases business strategies come up
with that rise that absolutely right and
everything art comes up with it business
comes up the way we manage comes up the
way we organize companies comes up and
what you'll notice is that not always
but typically as people rising through
they become more effective in their
management they become more effective
and totally there are some stages where
it kind of gets a little wonky for a
while but ultimately as as we do we get
better at what we're doing yeah yeah so
that's how I see it now I don't see it
as like spirituality though that's good
a lot of the methods that I'm using our
spiritual methods yeah we let's let's
stay on that thought that you started us
with which was that every child is on a
trajectory to unity yeah so so that
that's that's really fascinating in
itself as if there
not impeded by some sort of trauma or
some sort of economic or political
pressures that choke the unity out of
them right okay yeah mostly parenting
mostly parent I've been for the longest
time saying that the parent is the god
to the child yeah and it's the parents
responsibility to be a really good
leading figure for the child to to
figure out what they're passionate about
and you know yes I'll see that a lot and
it's not just God it's money which is
really weird so if you look at people
and if they had very authoritarian
parents that God is usually very
authoritarian and that very loving
parents their God is very loving also
the way they treat money is like that if
they're if the love was something that
they had to work for really hard
oftentimes their relationship with money
is something that they have to work for
really hard so oftentimes the the
parental relationship gets substituted
into money or God and and so oftentimes
with CEOs one of the things that I have
to work on is I don't have to I'd like
to work on is like how are we changing
the consciousness around money and and
that requires oftentimes work around
relationship with parents yeah okay so
let's let's let's stay here for just a
moment more so we have this child that's
born into the world and we have their
parents that depending on how they were
raised are raising the child and their
values are being shown to the child
sometimes they're these interesting
hacks like the child can be in school
and they can learn from like a side
angle about like environmentalism and
they can come home and be like yo we're
not using plastic water bottles right
more yeah and it's just ridiculous
because if the parent is like what how
does that happen yeah my values got
changed by my kid yeah yeah that's not
that's also kind of interesting that
that kind of development can occur yeah
so that's what we focus on the
philanthropy all the stuff we do is on
the consciousness of kids so we do
mindfulness in schools we do soul
self-organized learning environments
which are kind of the intellectual form
of
development inquiry-based development we
do hand-in-hand parenting so which is an
emotional form of the developmental
process this happens at ty Turner's no
no this is just my philanthropic that's
you see your philanthropic stuff you'll
actually go with parents and kid and go
through that process no so in the
philanthropic stuff what I do is I I
fund through the dbj foundation the the
dbj foundation we fund kids development
projects so we developed something
called inner Explorer when we got
involved it was like 20 classrooms
there's great leaders there they've done
a fantastic job but now it's been five
years and they're touching like six
hundred thousand kids or something like
that inner Explorer inner Explorer so
that's one souls start soul dot-org I
think it is also is another one that we
helped found and now in 20-something
countries is this a two-day workshop as
well no these are just nonprofits that
we support through philanthropy and then
they do sessions every yeah like the
mindfulness in schools is daily oh
mindfulness in schools and they'll go
and and unleash kind of an ecosystem of
teachers and - that's right yeah that's
Wow and they'll do mindfulness and
school practice yeah so there's they're
touching five hundred and fifty thousand
kids a year yeah Wow some of them weekly
bi-weekly some looks so great
yeah so and what I do there is that we
we put in a little bit of money and then
we put I put a lot of effort into
coaching those leaders so that they can
be effective and teaching them how to
scale organizations stuff that I learned
as a venture capitalist yeah okay yeah
okay so okay so now I could get more
about the philanthropically things okay
that's great that is that's wonderful
and by the way you're right it works the
kids meditate at school and then they
come home and they teach their parents
yeah you know I think mindfulness but it
yeah it's like a meditation yeah yeah
damn that is the next generation yeah
and I love that I love that yeah you
want to hear a story that I'll just
totally give you chills yeah yeah so I
was in Cleveland and then and we it was
one of the schools there and Cleveland
had taken this up I could get goosebumps
just thinking about this and there was a
kid in there
who was having a really really hard time
and what I was told by this teacher was
that he was failing in math and he just
got a hundred percent on a week where
his mom witnessed a shooting and had to
call the police to get a report for the
rental car that she had and so they beat
her up for calling the police and he
still got a great score 100% on this
test and so I sat to talk to him and I
said tell me what what's going on and he
goes I just want to thank you that was
it that way yeah I can that's all he had
to say it was just like I just want to
thank you like that's the power of this
stuff that's how calm the child totally
calm yeah
and it just aced a test yeah and that
obviously mindfulness doesn't do that
for everybody but it was a clear a clear
win and there's the hundreds of stories
like that yeah so so that's what yeah
that's what we do on the probably side
yeah whoa how old is the kid was in the
third grade yeah is that like 10 or nine
yeah oh my god I know right it's crazy
whoa yeah that is that is incredible
yeah it's it's so weird because some
people would you know argue that that
the child experiencing emotion is so
important yeah and then I guess maybe
what I would say to that is that that
child is experiencing an emotion but
they are not going absolutely bonkers in
the direction of absolute hate about the
past or about anxiety about the future
but rather they are just staying calm
they experience the emotion but they're
staying calm in the moment exactly if
you cut off the emotional a lot of
meditators will do that they'll like
meditate so they don't have an emotional
experience which really drives you in
the wrong direction I did it for seven
years I should know it's really
important to have that full emotional
experience but to be able to not see it
as who you are just see it as the wave
that's coming and moving through you and
has like a very deep level of
intelligence yeah we make decisions
emotionally like if I would hold
out the emotional center of your brain
it would take you a half an hour to
decide what color pen to use we are
emotional decision-makers and so the
question is and how do I make a logical
decision it's how do I get good with all
these emotions so I can make clear
decision how do I get good with the
waves that are just coming with that
clouds that are just coming over by
understanding that they are just
impermanent right and then another good
one that I thought of as you were
talking was that there was another good
way to understand
ah I think I lost it it might come back
but no problem just just I really
enjoyed that that essence of emotional
intelligence you're just you're really
you're teaching kids this and then that
that ends up catalyzing a much better
future moving forward that's the whole
idea the whole idea is if like if we can
get ten minutes - Lynn - ten million
kids hands and the emotional stuff we do
is hand-in-hand parenting which is
there's a great book listen by the woman
who wrote that and she yeah she amazing
book and that's really about that
emotional fluidity for kids having them
really be able to stay connected to
their emotional body right so if a kid
has trauma just as an example if you
were physically abused as a kid heavily
physically abused as an adult and you
hadn't gone through any kind of recovery
or healing as an adult I could put a
quarter in your hand or a key in your
hand or a can open in your hand and you
couldn't tell me what it was because
what the brain does is it disconnects
from the body because that's what needed
to happen which means all the signals
that the body has to tell you how to
live your life gets just cut off right
it's the same emotionally if somebody's
suffered a lot of emotional abuse they
don't have access to those emotions
they've just shut them down which
controls their life because they're
making decisions by how do I not feel
like a failure how do I not feel angry
how do I not feel sad yeah their whole
life is controlled by trying not to feel
some way which takes you know then you
have this many solutions instead of this
many solutions right if I'm like I'm
okay getting angry not angry at you
not being abusive but just having the
emotion of anger then I might pick a
path that I wouldn't pick otherwise yeah
I remembered what I was going to say
what was stress resilience right so you
got that wave coming and that wave was a
very stressful one whether it be anxiety
about the future or about hate about the
past and if you just realize that you're
just swaying like like a weeble wobble
to you know you're swaying to one side
and if you can have the homeostasis to
swing yourself back into equilibrium
yeah fast yeah you can you feel that
wave and get back to equilibrium and
even if you were to tell me something
that was very angry at me that I could
still feel it and then come back and say
that you know you know Joe why do you
feel that way right and rather than
replying again with anger and just
making it worse yeah I would even say
that the way I find most of the anxiety
in society today is just fear that is
unfelt
mmm right yeah I noticed like when we do
our really deep long extensive workshops
and we'll have some work in there where
people are deeply get in touch with
their fear as soon as it's done man the
the mind is silent everybody is calm you
can just feel the peace in the room
because they fully went into the fear
and fully had the release of that fear
instead of basically trying to manage it
all the time which is pushing it down
right in the set titers no ty Turner's
is kind of the entry level where was the
words this out we this is called it it's
called earth shakers it's an
eighteen-month shakers
yeah that's their theme of course yeah
and that's it's like you have to do a ty
Turner's and then we assess if you're
ready for the deeper or earth shake for
earth shakers yeah okay so let's yeah
let's unpack these now yeah yeah all
right so that was a lot of good stuff on
child development it stress resilience
and mindfulness that was really profound
I love that okay so now let's go titers
you've been doing this three years now
this is a two-day workshop a workshop
okay and so conscious development so
tell us about the
yeah so the two day workshop was
designed as a way like I want to give
people to like I'll put it to you this
way back in the day if you were studying
Zen all the things that you did in your
life there was a Zen way to do them
there was a Zen way to farm there's a
Zen way to drink tea there was a Zen
right but today we don't farm we don't
drink tea as a as a as a way of living
we mark it we dream self we we mark it
we sell we do things like that so what
are the tools that we can do those with
and actually be in our full authenticity
that's the thing that's really important
to me so tight earners is designed to be
a way of relating to each other that can
be brought into sales and product
development and management but also into
how you raise your children to how you
are in your marriage how you are with
friends so it's a really simple
technique that we just go over and then
the way the whole workshop is designed
is that is that we teach the state of
mind which is more important than the
technique by a felt experience is very
little talking and then once the state
of mind is crocked then we teach a very
simple technique and then we just say
okay let's go through all the problems
that we have and just solve them let's
just go through it and so people will
come in learn a technique and then
embody it by going through three or four
or five of their biggest issues in the
weekend and seeing the result of it and
seeing the result of it for other people
and then and then so it's like a really
embedded thing and we'll do sales issues
and we'll do marriage issues and we'll
take we'll take the technique to all
that stuff and we'll just practice it
that's what that's about and how does it
start out does it then start off with
people thinking about what their barrier
is in the sale or in the mirror they
don't need to know so how does it start
out then it's usually people come
because of conflict it's like you know
I'm fluent conflict usually people come
together conflict and I really they say
what their conflict is and then we got
to go to it and it how do you kind of
target like so if it's some conflict in
marriage or sales or whatever how do you
kind of end up figuring out what the
most optimal way for them to right
experience that that generative feeling
yeah so what we teach is that like if
you have the right state of mind it
always works out instead of strategy
instead of saying oh if I do this and
then I'll do this then I'll get to the
place that I want to be which sometimes
works and doesn't sometimes doesn't work
what works consistently is like if I can
show up in this way in the conversation
then a solution better than the one that
I'm managing for shows up so it's a
change of state of mind that's right
okay so you change your state yeah and
then the way that you approach the
action that you need to take will change
let's say and that way the result will
change right okay that's a very like
Robin's esque approach as well I
remember from his unleash the power
within different that we do is we do it
very relationally so most of the
workshop is in you do the work with
somebody else and so you're having
conversations versus the fifteen
thousand right one all right so instead
of me saying here's a way that you can
get to where you want its each other
facilitating each other do these deeper
experiences so they know they can do it
anywhere in their lives so then you will
see my lack in state my lack in kind of
I wouldn't call it a lack but oh yeah my
the growth that I have growth potential
that I have in changing my state to get
a change in a result in a change in an
action and then how do you then help how
would you help yeah yeah
so what we do is more it's a I frame it
a little bit differently because I think
that the idea that we are in Lac is one
of the biggest issues yet has to be
overcome
yeah right so for me the way I frame it
is here's a state of mind let's
experience it together and then I go
through a half a day of exercises so
people really understand that state of
mind and like what would one of those
like state of minds be the state of mind
is very vulnerable
it's very impartial it's very curious
it's very empathetic so that's that's
the state of mind that were that we're
going and how do we get to like a
vulnerable and emotional and pathetic
state of mind you got to come to the
workshop yeah so I have a series of
exercises where I do wear it it's I'm
playing with neuro chemicals and it's
just it just have
automatically things like eye contact
eye contact one where I do sometimes do
breath work oftentimes this eye contact
it's about how we relate to one another
it's all very relational and you get to
see how rewarding it is right yeah
most people think vulnerability means
weakness but vulnerability just means
doing the thing that you're a little
scared to do and people get to
experience Oh what if I do this little
scary thing oh my god that's so
rewarding yeah and so they get to
experience these kinds of things yeah
yeah and so oftentimes people have
massive revelations you know I have at
the end of the last tight earners that I
did up in Seattle I get a call from the
guy just a little bit later maybe a
month later he's like I successfully
fundraised my monastery we have an urban
monastery in Seattle funded right now
using that the tide Turner things I hear
about people changing their whole
business it's really it's really cool
stuff that happens from it that little
bit of a vulnerability that enables us
to grow that sort of connection that
you're talking about facilitating that
between people ends up if you can get
really good at these like just in this
2-day period of practicing these eye
contact and changing some of the
neurochemical balances within yourself
that then you will take that same
practice and embody it with your
relationships and with your business and
then that's kind of where this growth
happens because I've stopped stopped
treating other people as as just a means
to an end but rather start treating
other people as divine beings yeah
exactly but that's yeah you're treating
you're not solving their problems your
your help you're helping them see that
they solve their own problems if you're
doing anything at all that's a big part
of it yes a good way to think about it
is most of the people who come and pitch
me as a venture capitalist they go let
me tell you what we're doing and they
give me like they have no idea what I'm
interested in they're no idea what I'm
going for they're not so bright which is
a very different thing opposite way of
what you're supposed to do right walk in
there and asked other person about their
life and what they care about and see if
what you're doing is interesting to them
maybe
can actually help them yeah that's so
interesting that and then the other one
is like the same with marriage it's
usually if I'm in a marriage it's like
I'm having a hard conversation what my
mind is how do I get what I need or want
right how do I get them to stop doing
this or do the dishes or say the right
thing or love me the way that I want to
be loved and it's the same thing instead
of saying oh what's really going on here
and really owning what you want and then
allowing the natural intelligence to
move the whole situation so that's a lot
of what that work is yeah how would you
take a situation like a partner that
wants to be loved in a certain way but
that isn't being loved that way by their
partner and how would you know maybe
it's time to get the hell out of that
relationship yeah so without any details
that's a really hard thing to know but
what I and outside of being vulnerable
and being empathetic and being impartial
about this situation right a lot of the
times in a relationship there's
something that we don't want to feel and
it might be that we don't want to feel
it if they leave and it might be that we
don't want to feel it being in there but
almost all the time there's something
that we don't want to feel yeah and if
we allow ourselves to feel it instead of
manage our entire reality not to feel it
then the solution just presents itself
very very quickly but usually there's
just something in there that like
somebody doesn't want to feel right and
it's and the power dynamic whatever it's
gotten like that in relationship the
power dynamic is off also off there's
some way in which somebody feels more
powerful or less powerful or put-upon or
responsible or resentful that's always
in there in those relationships and so
the question that is like how do you
come at it internally in a different way
so that you can allow that person to be
exactly who they want to be and then you
make the decision do I want to be with
them or not rather yeah I want to change
that that's good that's interesting yeah
so then you you come come at it with a
with though kind of a love for them at
the moment that they're in no matter
what their energy they're in and then
you see themselves out there at their
fullest and not in a way that you want
to change them but then when you see
them that at that state then you
the decision of like is this someone
that I want to be with or not yeah under
what circumstances that's right but that
that's the main thing is that you're not
asking someone to change you're loving
them for who they are and you're not
asking them to change if is there ever a
time that let me just give you the
example if I ask you to change hey dude
like you should dress differently yeah
yeah what's immediately the thing that
happens in your system if I'm asking you
to change even though the thing that
immediately comes up is like it was like
right like and then but but for me I've
trained to myself right to really care a
lot about the recommendations that other
people are making for me right even if
they're coming at it very playfully and
kindly or if they're coming at me
harshly right I'm really starting to
just why like tell me why I should dress
differently
why should I speak to different why
should I ask these questions in a
different way I just I care a lot about
learning now than I do about like just
rejecting the advice that people get and
so that might be a conscious development
thing as well as is as long as this vibe
increases across the planet it'll be a
lot easier for us to take advice from
other people right yeah and and there's
something even in a three-year-old where
you're like tell them what to do and
they're gonna reject you know there's
gonna be that first movement and so if
you really want to have a deep connected
relationship with somebody then the
thing is to love them for what they are
who they are how they are and and then
see where they want to go and how they
want to develop and not put your agenda
on their life putting your agenda on
somebody's life is a form of aggression
yeah yeah it is
you know how well how does uh how does
one balance like loving someone for who
they are and when there is something
that is an aggressive energy that is
maybe coming from that person yeah
that's the where the boundaries are
really important that's where the
boundaries are really really important
so you know it would be not uncommon for
me to say I love you and I want to be
with you and if you treat me like this I
need to walk away yeah yeah the
opportunity is the boundary yeah there's
the opportunity is them too
be with me under these circumstances
because I get my life I get to be the
the person I want to be and be with the
people I want to be so I can stay loving
and I can also say these are the
circumstances in which I want to
interact with you in fact I would say
it's impossible to be loving without
those boundaries yeah you know like if
you look at Martin Luther King or if you
look at guns you'll get taken advantage
over you will get hurt
yeah it's but which isn't loving to
yourself or to them exactly or to them
yeah so if you look at Gandhi or Martin
Luther King they had their love required
boundaries and it's no different in a
marriage or anywhere else as a as a CEO
yeah I like that a lot yeah that's a
good one those boundaries yeah it's
important and teaching kids how to set
those up as well when they're young
teaching adults how to set them up
because we don't really yeah it's our
heart yeah but most adults can't really
even know and what they want fully it's
okay when you own what you want fully
yeah and then you have like maybe a
sit-down with the person that you want
to talk to and then you come in there
with the intention of of setting up a
boundary which is that I love myself and
I love you and that there's of this
boundary which is the way that you may
be aggressively approached me in this in
these types of situations
I can't that doesn't that doesn't help
myself love and I got it you know that's
my boundary yeah and that's a pretty
easy one in my opinion compared to
something else that's like you know vite
like actual physical violence that you
can't necessarily run away from the
mediator that it's really difficult to
run away from right and there's a lot of
that that happens on in the world still
so right yeah physical violence is a
crime and somebody the way to hold that
boundary is to call the police yeah I
mean that's a very different thing in
other places in the world it's not even
as that we can't even get away with
calling the police let's see the
interesting thing is what they've noted
so there's this great study that the CDC
did call about aces do you know what
aces are what is it adverse childhood
experiences okay okay being beaten
witnessing rape
these kinds of things and what's
interesting is the more of those that a
kid is experienced the more chance they
have like extremely greater chance of
being raped extremely greater chance of
being abused of having cancer of like
it's a ridiculous the more of these
traumas that these kids experience
especially if they don't have any tools
to work on those traumas the more they
are likely to be in abusive situations
to be yeah violated and so I don't know
how to solve you know
everything but what I do know is like
hey let's work with the kids of today to
work on those aces that's the place that
I know is a place to work yeah and then
if we can bring the traumatic stress
resilience back to a equilibrium and
then unleash their full potential that
process is so crucial otherwise yeah
like you said that we can get stuck yeah
then it's then it turns into the cycle
of violence I've also heard and maybe
this works within the aces as well that
that the that experiences that if your
roots reach down to hell then your tree
can really blossom towards the heavens
Oh interesting yeah yeah for me what
that means is that like you can't avoid
the pain you know the more that you can
invite and embrace the difficult
emotions the more joy there is so I have
a saying it's that the joy is the
matriarch of a family of emotions and
she doesn't come into a house where her
children aren't welcome so if you can't
allow for all the negative stuff then
real joy doesn't really take take root
in your life yeah
that reminds me a lot of what I was
telling you earlier about closing off
connections to people that I think are
less impactful and opening up
connections to people that are more
impactful yeah reminds me a lot of the
enabling yourself to experience joy by
closing off things that might disrupt
your flows of joy and that can be a
really harsh conversation to have with
people yeah which is that you know if
you can't meet me at my joyful stay if
you're gonna bring anger then I have to
disconnect yeah
what's interesting there is that a lot
of that can be also be denial so so the
way that I think about that is the way I
think about it is like so I would say I
would say it a little differently like
hey so this is what I want in my life
and what I notice is that when we're
together this is what happens you know
and so I'm wondering how do we want to
handle that because it's important to me
to get this thing that I want my life
and I'm not really I can't that's not
negotiable
yeah but how we get there together I'm
really open to okay and then I would sit
with like is what they're saying
something that actually resonates with
me if not like that doesn't quite work
for me but I would be open to the
conversation because that's where a lot
of growth happens that's where a lot of
learning happens and if it's not meant
to be then man it's over right and and
it happens really smoothly and really
nicely and not with a lot of drama
so yeah they don't feel rejected they
basically rejected you saying I don't
want to meet you in that way and that's
like okay cool the thing about that
approach is you really have to be open
to the heartbreak you have to really be
there and available for like oh right
like I really made myself vulnerable
here and they aren't able to meet me and
that's gonna break my heart and and the
good news is that heartbreak is what
increases our capacity to love but you
have to be open for it and I think a lot
of people draw those really hard
boundaries because they don't want to
experience the heartbreak it's like a
yeah versus being open to that emotion
of potential heartbreak which is when
you are completely open to that then
it's totally evident in the bond between
the two people as well like your
totally okay with them walking through
the door yeah exactly that's totally
evident yeah so even in my marriage
where you know like we have a really
good marriage but things happen and and
marriages evolve and there's moments
where it's like oh we're gonna have that
difficult conversation and my practice
is to actually experience the heartbreak
before I go into the conversation I
actually do like oh my god I might lose
my wife or whatever it is even if it's a
little dramatic
and then just fully have that feeling so
that when I go in I go in clean I go in
yeah really honoring what she wants and
honoring what I want this definitely
relates a lot to simulation because if
you're basically running simulations in
your mind and your body of what happens
if it goes the best and the worst the
middle though all these different ways
and then if you can run those
simulations and really feel those
feelings ahead of time when you go in
there and be totally okay with whichever
direction it takes but also another part
of that is just trying to go towards
growth and no matter where that growth
is yeah that growth takes you yeah I get
weary on that one yeah because because
our nature is to grow so I my experience
is the trying to grow gets in the way of
the growth so as an example like a
little kid they get this urge to be
physical it's like who there's my urge
to be physical and they just run and
they just play and they just do their
thing and adults oh I have an urge to be
physical and they go oh you know what I
really should get to exercise you know I
haven't exercised that much why am I not
working out really I have to work out
more why am I not doing that's right
that's what that's for thinking they
have this natural inclination and then
it gets kind of covered over by this
internal dialogue yeah right and so that
that's that's where I see growth is is
as soon as growth becomes a half-two or
something that I should do or something
that I need to do then a lot of the joys
taken out of it we just have this
natural desire to grow like it is what
we want to do it's like curiosity is
built-in to us and that's and and I say
trusting in that is a far quicker
process than thinking that there's
something wrong with you that has to be
thick
yeah like which is which is which is the
oak tree that's the perfect oak tree the
one that's 2 feet tall the one that's 10
feet tall the one that's 50 feet tall
the one that's dying like which is the
perfect oak tree there's also something
about looking in a mirror and seeing
ourselves for who we truly are oh yeah
and then I have to just burn off the
shitty parts of myself nice to just
admit that I have parts to myself like
that I want to burn off yeah and then
that objective process and then also
future authoring at the same time which
is I want in a month achieve this the
goal in a year to achieve this goal and
then that process will lead me on it on
you know more of a guided trajectory
towards growth towards objectives and
stuff like that yeah I obviously VC I
love goals I love measuring them I love
accountability and the balance to that
is when I was like 27 years old I was
like I'm gonna be brutally honest with
myself so I wrote on a list of
everything about myself that I didn't
want to admit and I folded it up and I
put it into a drawer and I forgot about
it just completely forgot about two
years later or maybe 18 months later I
pull out the list and I was like oh
let's see how much of this has changed
and I checked everything that had
changed and then I didn't check and then
I you know circled everything that
didn't I was like what do they have in
common and what they had in common was
the things that I checked I got done
were just things that I acknowledged and
never thought about again the ones that
hadn't changed were the ones that I was
like beating myself up for mm-hmm and
that that so it's it's I think having
the goals having the accountability is
beautiful but as soon as it becomes a
shame cycle it locks it into place
interesting huh huh okay okay cool um so
okay so that was that was really good
where we unpacked
child development as well where we
unpacked like what you're working on
with Ty Turner's and how that directly
applies to business and relationships
this is all great what do you think is
then the the future as of self
actualization we're coming into an era
where human capital is good for
repetitive work is not going to
needed we're entering in more of like an
ethical and moral dilemma with regarding
geopolitics with artificial intelligence
and biotechnology and all these
different pressing sort of technologies
around us yeah where do you think
actualization will come with augmented
reality technologies that can help us
with educational processes yeah like
what are you thinking about this yeah so
short-term is pretty easy you know
what's happening is corporations
especially cutting-edge corporations
that need to attract talent are making
human development more and more
front-and-center they have to because
the fact of the matter is you know you
know I'm gonna make a boatload of money
and I have somebody else that can make
me more boatloads of money so why do I
stay at your place why do I and I stay
because I'm satisfied because I'm happy
and if I belong to a community of people
who are effective and that feels good
and we're all growing you know we don't
we don't lose people that's well that's
well that's what we really want and so
that's what we stay for and the
companies that are doing that have great
retention rates and have great
performance so I think that's how
absolutely moving in that direction
especially when it comes to where you
really need Talent probably not gonna
happen so much in farming probably more
gonna happen in things like software but
I think that's that's one movement
that's occurring the second thing is in
bags and free food right right exactly
like at some point that wears off and
it's like do I feel connected with these
people yeah do I feel like I'm growing
as a person like if I leave this job am
I scared that I'm gonna stop Luton am I
gonna lose a community I care about if I
leave this job do I lose performance
that I care about meaningful work that I
care about if I leave this job do I lose
self growth that I care about
yeah those become the things and they've
always been the things that really
motivate people it's just we're learning
that it's really effective especially
with the cultural creative class and so
that's happening I think the other thing
is you were more and more technology is
going to start having an effect on how
we do things from virtual reality to
heart rate variability stuff but I think
we're just at the beginning of that and
like there's a technology I recently put
it on and it like puts you in
meditative state super quickly lots of
alpha waves balances the brain waves
from left and right brain so there's all
sorts of that kind of stuff that's
happening you're also seeing
electromagnetic stimulation of the brain
from the external so there's going to be
a whole bunch of that stuff and then AI
is gonna be obviously really interesting
I can't tell you what it looks like two
years out but over two years out but I
can say this is the stuff that's coming
in the next couple years my belief is
that we are meant to evolve so we will
evolve but evolving looks like the stock
market mmm sometimes there's downs
sometimes there's up I'm not smart
enough to catch those but I know overall
that this is the trajectory that we've
been on and will be on for quite some
time yeah the all the neuroscience some
in real time I of measuring that and
then being able to make changes to
balance go out towards equanimity and
that that is kind of nuts and then what
is equanimity as compared to what is
having an open heart as compared to like
yeah just because I be I'm able to
transcend my sense of self doesn't mean
that I have a big open heart loving
people and so there's different things
and we'll start to measure those and
really fascinating stuff that on the
horizon there I think generally where I
see it happening is that there's kind of
two levels of our society the level of
our society that's succeeding this is
going to become a more and more
important issue the level of our society
that is not succeeding it's going to
become more and more fire in the system
yeah and I think it's gonna be
extinguished through the race and
consciousness one hopes
yeah one hopes that's the race and one
taking action to get to that as well
right there okay couple quick questions
on the way out that I think are really
important you have ty Turner's coming up
this weekend yeah last one where yeah
we'll have a link in the bio as well of
course there's like three slots left so
so get in get in it we're going to do it
yeah
in Berkeley Berkeley Koran Berger Dharma
college at our college so so couple
quick questions on the way out we
typically like to ask our guests about
this to hear what their thoughts are
what do you think about us being alone
in the cosmos
statistically super unlikely yeah and
and also what I would say is if you are
the cosmos how are you not alone or how
are you alone yeah yeah it doesn't like
that if you are the cosmos how are you
alone yeah yeah that's interesting I
like that yeah and then how about do you
think that you exist in this physical
form do you think you exist elsewhere I
think I don't exist I think you don't
exist yeah yeah I have a funny story on
that I had a bumper sticker that's a
honk if you don't exist and I was in LA
and the funniest thing was nobody
everybody nobody honked and like three
times in LA in eight years people honked
and every time they did I was like what
what's so angry yeah and I was like oh
they're honking at that thing which was
this beautiful reminder of my own
consciousness but teach us why you think
that the sense of self is is isn't is
okay okay so here it is in your
everybody's mind there's a voice in the
head and the voice in the head might say
something like you really need to
exercise more or might say you you
should develop more or whatever so which
one is you is it the one that's talking
or is it the one that it's talking to
like which one of those is you and if if
that is me then why can't I control it
like I can say I'm walking because I'm
walking but if I say I'm thinking it's
kind of weird because I can't stop
myself from doing it which means it's
like who's the me there that's what I
mean I mean that the sense of self when
it when it sees what it truly is it's
not it's not a me anymore
uh-huh okay so once you start digging in
you realize that the sense of self as an
illusion correct it's a construct of
thought it's a concentrate of thoughts
okay
so then where do you take that in
relation to non-existing right yeah
right so just to go back on it for a
second it like so if I like if I cut you
in half which side is you right like so
there's all these ways we define
ourselves well my physical form but I'm
different physically today than I was
yesterday so which one of those is me so
there's the physical form and then
there's the identity of thought form
which is I'm the person who's been
thinking all this stuff but I can't
control that thought and am i different
if I'm thinking different stuff so all
of that means that the sense of self
that we identify as an eye is the
illusion but that doesn't mean that this
doesn't exist this here it is apparent
okay so the eye is the illusion but but
the physical form is was real apparently
hardly okay do you think that we are in
a simulation yeah that yes I think we're
in a simulation I'm not sure if it's
computer automated simulations or I
actually think that the simulation is so
what's interesting is I just was talking
about this okay you're gonna have to
give me a little patience okay so so the
idea is that there's something
generating our simulation and we're
walking around in the simulation I would
suppose that the simulation is actually
in the brain like we see these colors
because our simulation model sees these
colors instead of a higher spectrum we
are capable of X kinds of thoughts and
not other kinds of thoughts because our
simulation so so it's it's a pretty
clear thought process for a very long
time that most of what we see is a
projection both physically I'm only
seeing like a quarter around everything
else is generated by the brains
algorithms right so there's both that
and that's a neuroscience unknown fact
so we're generating through calculations
so to speak our world around us we know
that that's happening but we also are
projecting like if I think
it's really cool to wear a green shirt
then I'm gonna think that you think I'm
cool for having the green shirt if I
think green sucks you're I'm gonna think
that you think you're judging me because
I'm wearing green like that's how we
walk around the world like somebody
wants to be rich thinks everybody thinks
it's cool if they're rich that's we just
project we project all over the place so
that's the way in which I see we're
walking around in a simulation yeah okay
and then okay last question yeah last
question is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world right now
it's accreted six great questions yeah
never get asked those questions that's
really fun so so right now yeah okay
over and over again yeah that's all I
got that's all I got yeah yeah that's
great Joe that's so good thank you
you're welcome and thank you very much
thank you this has been such such a
pleasure yeah yeah I really appreciate
coming on the show and teaching us about
working on like an important and sharing
with us all this unique perspective
really it's great cool thank you I
enjoyed it thanks for inviting me I
appreciate it yeah I'm really looking
forward to exploring more cool yeah I
hope that happens yes yes I want to
thank everyone for tuning in if you guys
had a good time give us a comment below
with your thoughts we would love to hear
from you also don't just consume go and
create go to make a blog or and make our
core make business go and make video go
to create with this we want to give a
shout out to Michael manky our producer
director for this show thank you huge
thanks to Michael and join us in more
conversations in the future join us in
the community thank you everyone for
tuning in
much love